[Music]
greetings and welcome to this
celebration of the Yale School of
Nursing class of 2020 it's an honor to
be able to share in this special day
with you and to commemorate this
important milestone
while we are sad we cannot be together
for our usual festivities in New Haven I
am grateful that we can gather virtually
across space and time to mark the
occasion let me begin by thanking all
those watching loved ones faculty staff
and mentors who have supported our
extraordinary graduates during their
time at ysn as they work to become the
nurses midwives health system leaders
and nurse scientists that the world is
desperately calling for right now
congratulations to every single one of
our graduates on crossing this finish
line I'll be it virtually it's an
understatement to say that the world was
a different place when you started at
Yale School of Nursing those years ago
it was different even just a few months
ago some of you had only just begun your
nursing journey while others came to why
ascend to build on years of Nursing
experience you had clear goals and an
inspired vision for how your education
would progress in any journey bumps on
the road can be expected assessed and
dealt with accordingly
and often these bumps lead to the
greatest growth a clinical rotation may
alter the direction of a career a
professor's comment may inspire a new
research thread and a project may launch
a movement no matter how you started you
are finishing as Yale nurses you
answered when the world called you've
handled your last semester with grace
grit flexibility and determination and
you are to be applauded for that from
here you will set forth as a healer at a
time when society is facing
unprecedented need
no simulation has prepared the world for
Kovan nineteen's impact but i trust that
you can take everything you learned at
ysn coupled with the different
experiences you brought with you and
helped lead your communities out of a
pandemic that has made clear society's
disparities weaknesses and fragilities
the Cova 19 pandemic will remake US and
Yale nurses must help remake society to
be more just through your work in the
health systems universities and other
workplaces across the country as Yale
nurses you will be joining communities
and institutions that needs you more
than ever
congratulations class of 2020 we are so
proud of you
I am honored now to recognize
exceptional individuals from our
community who have been nominated by
students and faculty for teaching
scholarship service and research through
our annual recognition process any
goodrich the founding dean of Yale
School of Nursing was an outstanding
nurse leader an educator whose vision
set the course for nursing education the
very origins of our school emerged from
the ashes of another worldwide
conflagration World War one we honor her
legacy through the Annie Goodrich Award
for Excellence in teaching by
recognizing a faculty member who carries
on the tradition of exceptional nursing
education each year students nominated
faculty members highlighting their
outstanding teaching skills professional
activities and effectiveness as a role
model availability and support for
students and community activities
this year's recipient exemplifies
nursing excellence through her
commitment to all students during the
Cova 19 outbreak she recognized a need
for a change in seminar she created a
space for students to talk about their
concerns with their jobs homes and
families she started each soon call with
a mindfulness exercise and encouraged
students to bring her exercises they
could facilitate with the group as a
preceptor liaison she has built many
trusting relationships with clinicians
in the community and is working to
spread why ascend psychiatric mental
health nurse practitioner students
through different levels of care she is
also an instructor who teaches across
programs and has transformed the
teaching experience and classroom space
for the gebben students this year we are
proud to present the 2020 Annie Goodrich
Award for Excellence in teaching to an
amazing advisor faculty member and
mentor dr. Dilys Robertson
congratulations and thank you dr.
Robertson
the Charles King jr. memorial scholars
aid prize is given to a graduating
student who has demonstrated outstanding
performance in scholarship research and
clinical practice and who through
accomplishments in and leadership of all
aspects of study has inspired an
admiration for professional nursing work
the recipient has proven herself to be
the quintessential APRN to be she
actively sought out experiences in
Community Health through her
volunteerism at the Haven free clinic
through her request for and completion
of a rotation with the Yale community
health care van through her
participation in the gender sexuality
and health justice concentration and
through her work in Tijuana Mexico
providing prenatal care primary care and
other services with the refugee health
alliances organization she is
compassionate astute and approachable to
all individuals with whom she interacts
she continues to be a leader in nursing
knowledge through her work as a med surg
nursing ta her ongoing work with the
minority student Nurses organization and
in her professional life serving on
behalf of underserved populations and
she embodies forward-looking action as
she said about another celebration the
gap and graduation our work here as
nurses students and activists is just
beginning it's a great pleasure to award
the 2020 Charles King jr. Memorial
scholars aid prize to camille lawhead
congratulations miss lawhead the Milton
and and Sydney Prize is awarded to a
graduating student whose research in the
judgment of the faculty best exemplifies
the school's commitment to clinical
scholarship and its mission to
contribute to better health for all
people
this year's recipient has produced an
in-depth exploration of vaginal birth
after cesarean section be back in the
United States her integrative review
exposed the facilitators and barriers
identified in the literature of
accessing VBAC in the u.s. her study of
2017 birth certificate data is the first
large data set state-by-state
demographic and geographic examination
of be back her mixed methods
dissertation research uncovered graphic
stories of women's struggles to have
vaginal births after prior cesareans
sometimes forcing them into unsafe
choices such as giving birth in a hotel
room near a hospital that would not let
them labor in their facility
she found that women who felt
disrespected or lacked autonomy were
less likely to plan a me back this
nominee has six national and
international presentations or posters
and during her doctoral program her
dissertation research was supported by
the March of Dimes Margaret Comerford
Freda saving babies together award the
association of women's health obstetric
and neonatal nurses and the Rockefeller
University hellbrunn Family Center for
nursing research noting the depth and
care of her work
I am honored to award the Milton and Ann
Sidney prize to dr. Bridget Lynn
Bastille Ibrahim congratulations dr.
Ibrahim it's now my pleasure to
introduce one of our graduating students
danielle um in the adult gerontology
primary care nurse practitioner
specialty who will address the class of
2020 I still remember the first day I
stepped into my son a little excited a
little nervous and very much determined
I was very like a yellow hoodie that my
parents bought me to congratulate me on
getting accepted to the program all
throughout orientation
I remember twirling my hoodie strings
and thinking in my mind of what to say
to my new peers so so that make a fool
out of myself first introductions and a
bit of awkwardness is now something I
can look back on and laugh about with my
cohort or not my friends we have all
come a long way
fought through our own struggles and
managed to make it to the finish line
hand in hand so
where do we go from here some of us will
continue our journey in academics
following the footsteps of our DMP and
PhD colleagues earning doctoral degrees
becoming researchers and professors some
of us may dive back into the clinical
field working as advanced practice
nurses at private practices or
university hospitals or maybe were
working for the CDC
I shared even busy these days the
possibilities are almost dauntingly
unless but no matter what we all decide
to do with our degrees there is one
common point what will ties together is
our shared heritage in the practice of
Nursing we are all about to embark on
careers that require the highest levels
of empathy and compassion
we are committed selfless unified brave
and fierce multitaskers this is the
common point that I have seen it every
single one of my classmates alongside
our fellow health care providers in
various specialties we tested our
strengths during these unprecedented
times with a kovin 19 pandemic we
volunteered at local clinics we work
long seemingly hopeless shifts in the
ICU we help with hotline calls from
terrified potential patients we video
chatted our friends and family her
questions and concerns about possible
symptoms we came together as a community
to get their commencement cancellations
we shared resources and knowledge and
reached out to one another through it
all we have become more aware of what's
at stake and we have proved resilient
and knit together even closer we are the
grassroots we are the heartbeat
we are the frontline warriors the massed
army as Yale nurses may we never forget
where we started where we come from let
us also not forget our sense of pride
and this honorable call of duty that
fills us all with fire today more than
ever the field of Nursing has become
vital in health care and the demand for
nursing professionals in the United
States alone is expected to increase
drastically in the coming years we are
basing our time
when our expertise and dedication is
desperately needed at hospitals and
clinics all over the world and now it is
our turn to step up and fully embrace
these responsibilities as we go out into
the real world with all training wheels
off may we not be afraid to step out of
our comfort zones
may we be willing to work in underserved
communities and may we never forget why
since mission better health for all
people I like to close by giving thanks
to where they are due first two are
amazing wives and staff who put up with
our endless emails and questions and
solved all of our beauty difficulties to
our professors who have guided us so far
and taught us what it takes to become a
true Yale nurse to our family and loved
ones
thank you for your unconditional love
and support we would not have been able
to do this without you and to our peers
who pushed and motivated each other to
keep faith in the vision and trust the
process in the future we may look back
at our time at wise then I'm texting
your friend every morning asking them
what class room to go to for getting
your student ID to get into the building
talking about our future holds for us in
the hub celebrating the end of every
semester and studying in the study rooms
for hours on end I hope that those
memories bring me joy and most
importantly I hope they keep you
grounded and motivate you to work
together appreciate others and learn
more in order to be the best you can be
for your patients as someone quoted
Nightingale on the whiteboard on the
ground floor of Weinstein let us never
consider ourselves finished nurses for
we must be learning all of our lives
thank you for listening and deepest
congratulations to us the class of 2020
thank you everyone for joining us today
to celebrate our graduates brave and
fierce please join me in a toast to
congratulate them on this special
passage and to wish them our heartfelt
best in all their future endeavors we
are so proud of you and look forward to
everything you will share with the world
a world ready for healing
graduation congratulations Yale nursing
class of 2020
so happy for you to reach this milestone
and I want you to know that I'm sending
you my happiness from wherever you are
all corners of the world celebrating
that we are with you and we are so
excited about all the remarkable
contributions that you're gonna make to
this world
lots of love congratulations hello this
is Aaron McMahon from the midwifery
specialty saying congratulations to the
class of 2020 we are so proud of you and
all the hard work that you have put in
over the last few years demonstrating
your strength resilience and commitment
to patient care I want to thank you for
allowing me to share my passion for
referring and nursing with you and for
the opportunity to learn alongside of
you we are so excited to see the great
things that this class is going to do
congratulations from the grounds of
campus congratulations young nurses of
2020 you did it you deserve this moment
I want you to remember three things when
you're taking care of patients and
communities you do it with passion and
compassion that is the Yale way number
two please take care of yourself that is
so important in being a nurse and number
three you'll always be a Yale nurse keep
in touch
congratulations everyone congratulations
Yale if you care MP grand on behalf of
the faculty of the Yale School of
Nursing and the Graduate School of Arts
and Sciences we want to congratulate the
three students who have completed their
PhD degree this year and they are
bridgett bazzill Abraham and Krista
Knudsen and Abigail wilfers we wish you
the very best going forward
congratulations organizations ysn fnps
class of 2020 I am so incredibly proud
of you you have so much to be proud of
in this very moment over the past three
years you've proven that nothing is
impossible you've put your lives on
complete halt to conquer your dreams
you've overcome adversities you've
challenged yourselves to do better and
to be better you have done it I'm so
proud of each and every one of your
accomplishments you have sincerely
persevered you've exhibited unwavering
strength you've demonstrated commendable
courage I challenge each and every one
of you just to remember where you came
from stay humble always be kind treat
all of your patients as if they were
your family accept criticism with grace
and of course never stop learning I for
one am someone that is so grateful that
each and every one of you has been
chosen to enter this most heroic
profession we need more health care
providers like you in this world so
welcome aboard I wish you nothing but
success and happiness in your future
just remember to always believe in
yourself this world is waiting for you
to heal it one person at a time
congratulations on an amazing job we
will miss you but we are so so proud of
you congratulations class of 2020 I'm
very proud of you this is an amazing
accomplishment the world right now needs
you
we need nurse practitioners like you we
need midwives like you we need nurse
scientists like you
we need nurse leaders like you this is a
time for the other nurses to really go
out and serve the world you all are
prepared you all have made an amazing
accomplishment I look forward to serving
with all of you in the field in the
future
a class of 2020 it's finally over now
the fun begins you're going to be doing
what you wanted to do it was a dream and
it's now before you everything is
important but as you're all well aware
everything is never enough so stay open
and curious and be adventuresome the
world needs you so go there is much work
to be done we will miss you and we're
very proud of you
good luck hi guys I just want to say
congratulations to the 2020 keep your
nurse practitioner grads we're here in
our ICU and you guys are gonna be front
lighters pretty soon so I'm really
really proud of you
I also found a former grad who's
recently been a patient to give you a
little talk some advice and to sing a
song so congratulations again
congratulations to all neil graduates
and especially the whyisign graduates
and especially of acute-care graduates
of 2020 my name is Andy Saleh I am also
a Yale graduate from the acute care
program and dr. Laura andrews asked me
to say a few words to all of you
considering we're all held up in our
homes and can't have a graduation so
like all of you you are now like birds
you have migrated long distances
together and Yale you have made friends
and grown I'm sure in ways I never
thought possible only a few years ago my
best advice from an alum standpoint from
a provider standpoint and from also a
patient standpoint is make sure that you
treat your patients and really everyone
for that mad
like you were sitting in that hospital
bed again I'd like to thank y'all for an
especially ysn for the springboard that
allowed me to kind of jump on and find
new experiences I wish you all the best
and I know you all have a variety of
different jobs but the vocation that you
all share will always be the same
and you will give the world better
health for all people so thank you very
much and congratulations graduates
congratulations class of 2020 just
sending this celebratory video I'm so
happy for you guys this has been a long
hard journey I know it's probably not
how you envisioned your commencement
would go but it doesn't change the fact
that this is such an important milestone
in your life so proud of all of you it's
just such an amazing fantastic
accomplishment and I'm so proud to have
all of you go out into the world as
nurse practitioners congratulation happy
graduation day PEP class of 2020 we are
so proud of you and wanted to share just
a few clinical pearls before we send you
out into the world we just like to take
this opportunity to tip my hat to you
and to wish you congratulations on your
graduation and I used to be very proud
of all that you've accomplished these
past few years during your time at lisen
I've really enjoyed getting to know each
of you whether it be in sort of the
large classes or the medium-size classes
or even over in the clinic so again
congratulations going forward one I
guess thing I would hope you would do is
consider connecting with and
contributing to the work of your
professional organizations and
associations whether it be on a state
national or international level groups
such as nap-nap or the association for
nurse practitioners or sigma whatever
would best meet your interest
I think you'll find that's a way to sort
of be grounded to continue your own
development to contribute to the
profession
and actually a way to make some lifelong
friends so I really hope you will
consider that again congratulations to
each of you so thank you and I will pass
the hat on to the next person thank you
take care as you move on to the next
step in your journey I always want you
to remember how much you know and how
ready you are for this PNP class of 2020
we are so proud of you congratulations
to all wise and graduates
never forget the importance of
development and parent-child attachment
congratulations to our newest PMPs
a seal nurses always remember to think
outside of the medical box remember how
family and psychosocial factors
influence the care you give today in
tomorrow congratulations
hello new PMPs
it's a great honor and a great privilege
to be a nurse practitioner and to
establish relationships with families
and children to follow them all along
the way through the good times and the
more difficult everyone just remember to
read an article a day my pearl for all
of you is that 80% physical assessment
comes from observation and you got to
get what you can get when you can get it
I'm so excited for all of you you will
have a wonderful life and pediatric
nurse practitioner
congratulations you have an important
job ahead of you Frederick Douglass said
it best it's easier to build strong
children than to repair adult nice throw
so not to worry this isn't part three of
your adolescent exam
my clinical pearl would be to make sure
that you make every clinical service
that you work with adolescent friendly
and remember that continuity truly
matters in building trusted
relationships with your adolescent
patients and their families hi class of
2020 I have so much gratitude for each
of you and the learning that we have
done together these last years and
gratitude for the ways you have inspired
and supported me to be a better teacher
and leader and I am wishing you so much
support as you enter the world now as
nurse practitioners and midwives and
become the champions of health and
justice that I know that you can be and
that you already are congratulations
congratulations to the class of 2020 I
just wanted to share a few thoughts as
you start your journey you know
preparing nurses is different than
preparing students for other kinds of
work there's an ethos conveyed because
Nursing is more than a job it's a
mission and a way of looking at the
world I've enjoyed watching as each of
you have taken on this ethos now I wish
you the courage to be the advanced
practice nurse you have worked so hard
to become and I wish you the grace to
flow with the ripples that will come our
way in the future we wish that you will
travel places and see things and meet
people and do things you've never
imagined you would do
and most of all we hope that you
continue to follow our mission of
bringing better health to all people and
what do I wish for us well that you let
us know what you're up to when you visit
New Haven that you stopped in or say a
hook to say hello or you could message
us just to stay in touch congratulations
the psych Mental Health faculty sent all
of our best wishes to all of you to the
2020 graduates of Yale University's
Doctor of Nursing Practice program in
healthcare leadership systems and policy
the faculty and I wish you our warmest
and most celebratory congratulations you
are now among the three percent of
nurses in the United States who take
their place at the highest levels of
leadership in our healthcare system on
that note and as our program motto says
you are now truly today's leaders who
will go on to create the health care
system of tomorrow and we couldn't be
prouder of you congratulations to the
class of 2020 congratulations from the
clinical Support Unit
you should be proud of all the
accomplishments you have made over the
past two to three years and while this
semester has been anything but ordinary
neither are you as you embark on your
new clinical career we wish you all the
best we can't wait to see the amazing
things you will do and we can't wait to
have you back to help educate a future
Yale nurse
[Music]
hello everyone congratulations on your
graduation I'm so excited for you and
I'm so excited to see the next steps
that you're going to take into your ears
I know that you're gonna do amazing
things and get snacks for you best
wishes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
to each and every one of you graduating
this year we are so proud of you
everyone here at ysn has been rooting
for you and we couldn't be happier for
you at this time of celebration we know
you're going to go far and you're gonna
have every success in the world so time
to pop back cork and enjoy the
celebration Cheers
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
[Music]